[Music]
let me let me welcome all of you to the
this next session in the worlds of
speculative fiction today we're dude we
were looking at a follow Muskaan tonight
August Derleth very interesting guy
there's a lot of mixed opinions on him
and we're looking primarily at his we
can't even say his interpretation of the
Cthulhu Mythos because he's the one who
makes up the name Cthulhu Mythos so his
is building off of Lovecraft but he's
also really well-known for for a few
other things another one of them is his
solar ponds series where he's taking off
of Arthur Conan Doyle's Sherlock Holmes
stories basically he's not plagiarizing
as such but he's basically stealing the
character and it went to such an extent
that that Arthur Conan Doyle's sons
tried to get legally stopped in the rows
and then he also writes does this
massive body of literature that you
could call I guess Wisconsin Wisconsin
ah Mia you know the these the sand
Prairie stories that he writes which he
gets a Guggenheim Fellowship for fairly
early in his career too right that's
that's one of his main lines what's up
and he oh you just wrote volumes and
volumes of stuff so what we'll talk a
bit about that stuff but we're mostly
going to focus on his connection with
Lovecraft what we usually do in these is
is that we talk about bit of the
person's biography but it is so there's
it's called worlds of speculative
fiction and particles we focus on the
world building that happens within the
body of work
the the novelist or a short story writer
and in this case it's it's you know well
we'll get into it but it's he takes
somebody else's narrative universe as he
does with other things and then he puts
his own spin on it that some people are
you know think it's quite good and other
people think is the worst thing to
happen to the body of literature
altogether than others people in between
so he's a very you know quite quite
interesting character there's a lot of
criticism of him some of the criticism
of him is is really for not criticizing
Lovecraft enough as well to talk about
because Lovecraft you know was a great
writer but he was also you know quite
clearly a hardcore racist and and
probably wouldn't have even liked if
he'd known you know durable its ancestor
he probably wouldn't even have liked
Derleth all that much and you know
there's some other unsavory things that
having to do with like a fascination
with at that time fascism that Lovecraft
had that the Derleth kind of papered
over a bit so we'll talk about that as
well and then there's there's other
criticized Derleth because he's not
Lovecraftian enough because he's you
know he's not writing you might say up
to the standard of Lovecraft or he's
doing a different kind of project so
he's a really paradoxical figure and I
think it's really cool that he's
somebody from here yeah from I mean not
here Brookfield but we could get on the
road and drive two hours and we could
get to Sauk City and you know see the
bridge named after him and the house
that he grew up in and all of those
sorts of things we can't say that about
a lot of the authors that we we look at
so I let's start with the the his
biography and what one thing that is
kind of nice he doesn't move around a
lot so most of this is actually
happening in Sauk City he does get down
to Madison
every once in a while to lecture at UW
he also goes to school there he'd go up
to Minnesota every so often he clearly
had an interest in Milwaukee because he
actually writes about the Milwaukee Road
and in one of his books and he did go
out to California and did one semester
as a guest lecturer out there but for
the most part he's just staying in Sauk
City he's born to William and Rose
Derleth his ancestry is is you know
partly partly French partly Bavarian
there were a lot of Germans who had
emigrated to two parts of Wisconsin
after the Revolution of 1848 and so Sauk
City was one of the places small town
but one of the places where a lot of
those eighteen forty-eighters have gone
and they're part of what gave Wisconsin
our heritage of you know progressivism
and socialism and you know we've had
socialist mayors in Milwaukee which is
kind of a rare thing but you know still
based around farming communities and
stuff like that and derma thumb you know
it goes to the local schools he reads a
lot of pulp fiction and writes his first
short story in in 1922 at 13 years old
in part to see whether he can do what
the people that he's reading are doing
which you know makes makes good sense
and he thinks that maybe you could
actually you know make a living at it he
starts writing stuff and that starts
sending it out and gets like 20
rejection notices while he's 13 14 and
15 you know that would be kind of tough
i I don't think I could stick with then
but he does when his parents are
supportive you know he finally sells
bats belfry to Weird Tales when he's 16
that's his first publication and the
year after that he graduates when he was
17 and goes to you know University of
Wisconsin and while he's there he starts
a correspondence with HP Lovecraft
and he will eventually become the person
who edits and publishes Lovecraft's
letters interestingly I have read
through the letters that they have
Lovecraft will will write like page
after page after page to this person his
letters to Derleth early on they're
pretty short yeah they're sort of like
you know he's already nowadays would
call a fanboy and you know asking the
the sort of you know questions that
people do where do you get your ideas
that's Lovecraft you know he's very nice
and he responds to him and they they you
know they have this nice correspondence
to together that lasts over time and it
gets bigger and bigger and bigger and
Derleth likes Lovecraft stories that's
very clear but he also likes a whole
bunch of other people as well and
eventually he graduates from from
uw-madison gets his BA and he takes a
post briefly in Minneapolis with Fawcett
publications as an editor on this mystic
magazine he only stays there for a short
time then he goes back to Sauk City
moves back in with mom and dad who are
again supportive of his work and he says
I'm going to become a professional
writer and you know he's got a track
record by that time of selling some
stuff he publishes his first work a
heritage of Sauk City which is you know
if you think about it he was really
fascinated with with place and a little
bit of a digression here so he he
considered himself a pulp writer but
also a regional writer and he thought of
Lovecraft
as also being a regional writer because
because New England plays such a wall
there so you're going to see a lot more
things focused on this area he starts
writing mystery novels for a new press
luring and and moosie and why does he do
that
closed-cell there's lots of people who
want
to do mystery things and so you know
some of these early things like murder
stalks the Wakely family sign of fear
three who died those of those are in
their place of hawks is is regional and
stuff and then in 1937 HP Lovecraft who
was it was never in good health he dies
and Lovecraft has a literary executor
who at that time is a fairly young guy
Barlow Robert Barr who later on become
an anthropologist you know helped to
decipher Aztec and Mayan monuments and
and he would teach in various places but
at that time he's a young guy and some
people think that that that really
Derleth and his buddy
Donald wanderer should stayed out of
everything but Derleth capitalizes on a
letter in which Lovecraft sort of hints
that maybe endureth will be as literary
executor to sort of stiff-arm this this
kid out of the way and say we're gonna
be able to publish Lovecraft stuff you
know leave it to us and eventually
Barlow just sort of signs things over
there's a lot of controversy about how
this was handled it may be the case that
Derleth did start rumors about Barlow it
may not be the case you know there's a
lot of he-said she-said stuff going on
there but what ends up happening is is
Derleth and and wandering they get
Lovecraft stories and by this time you
know Lovecraft was a pulp writer so pulp
stuff it exists in the the magazines
that it's in and then when those
magazines go out of circulation
the stories are done they'll be in
libraries but you know the pulp stuff is
it is really crappy paper that's why
it's it's Paul so it breaks down very
easily and unless you republish it
things can quite easily get lost so they
think Lovecraft is
he's so great we need to keep his stuff
in circulation they start going around
to publishers and nobody wants to
publish it and around this time sort of
in a different vector Derleth gets gets
a you know Guggenheim Fellowship but he
gets this in part because Sinclair Lewis
and other people lobbying for him yes so
it was he was sponsored by UW English
professor Helen white as well as
Sinclair Lewis and Edgar Lee masters so
he handsome pole and the Guggenheim
Fellowship gives him you know plenty of
money and the idea is he's supposed to
bill allowed this entire this entire set
of novels and short stories he
anticipates 50 volumes centered around
Wisconsin stories mostly you know sort
of realist novels and he did write a lot
that that's the bulk of his writing
actually but he uses the money enough he
uses the money to bind his comic books
because he thinks comic books are
actually a you know an important Georgia
code an important genre and he realizes
that they're gonna break down if they're
not preserved well so that's what he
uses a lot of his Guggenheim money to do
he's still living at home too so he can
afford to do that sort of thing and then
in 1939
you know the publishers have just not
been interested in publishing
Lovecraft's stories so he says well
we'll start our own press any forms
Arkham House Arkham House will become a
very important press not only for
Lovecraft
but for speculative fiction much more
broadly speaking and we'll also publish
things like Robert blokes psycho and
other
you know through throughout you know the
20th century and so Arkham House is is
originally founded to give them this
flexibility to publish stuff and that's
when he does start getting Lovecraft
stories together and publishing them he
also starts doing things that some
people are willing to call
collaborations and other people say are
really him you know publishing his own
stuff under Lovecraft's name and in
other cases you know taking Lovecraft's
materials and you know touching them up
himself and saying they're
collaborations he plays a little fast
and loose with some of these things and
the ones that I've gotten in black on
this are things that are Lovecraftian
you could say in 41 he becomes literary
editor of madison's the capital times
and so he's got to go to Madison every
didn't every so often Sauk City is not
that far from Madison 42 wand ray enters
the army and that's really most of his
that that's not completely the end of
his connection with Arkham House later
on when Derleth dies he'll he'll resume
some services but for the most part wand
raise is not going to be that involved
and notice that just how many works
Derleth is churning out in those years
some of them are Wisconsin things some
of them are Lovecraftian things like
some someone in the dark
HP Lovecraft a memoir something near
marginalia is one of those things where
he takes Lovecraft stuff and kind of
puts his own spin on it not long for
this world later on in 48 not 1949
something about cats and other pieces is
another taking Lovecraft's things and
turning it into
collaboration as a matter of fact I've
got one of the collaborations right here
that's from the Marquette library the
watchers out of time and others by HP
Lovecraft and August Derleth right now
some of these things were ostensibly
Lovecraftian and others maybe not quite
so much and there's there's a great
foreword by April Derleth who takes over
his daughter who takes over our
compressed
yeah after luck or after Darryl a--the
eyes and yeah like at 5:00 this little
passage she writes when Lovecraft died
in 1937 Derleth was one of the few to
recognize him as a prominent figure in
the domain of supernatural horror that
recognition was to develop into a quasi
obsession a personal commitment to see
that loves craft obsession would be
contained within hardcovers and you know
she talks about them collaborating
she says the title story for this book
was a long time coming it was to be the
final collaboration and perhaps
significantly Durrell ahthe was at work
on this story at the time of his death
in July 4 on July 4th 1971 the story is
about half complete but sufficiently so
to enable the reader to apply his own
imagination and reach his own
conclusions the editors of Arkham House
felt that this story should be published
in its incomplete form so as not to
distort the essential literary quality
of Derleth and symbolically bring to
close a great literary life now she's
saying that they're collaborating in
1971 Lovecraft has been dead now at that
point in time for more than 30 years so
I'm not sure you really come with a
colon aberration and as he's writing
with a why do the irony is we were going
to get into this a little bit so Derleth
and then Lovecraft they have different
basic you could call them philosophies
of life death the cosmos and stuff like
that during live as a practicing
Catholic
but but he's he's he's not one of those
Catholics who thinks that like there's
only the the supernatural as you know
understood and interpreted by the church
he's fairly Catholic in a broad in his
taste
Lovecraft is a by his own words a
scientific materialist
he doesn't buy into any any of that sort
of stuff you know if there was gonna be
any sort of you know survival of
something after death it would be like
vibrations of energy or something like
that and how the hell would you know
that it's Lovecraft
so it's there's there's a discordance
there but anyway coming back to this so
I think I did I mentioned this just
before we started or did I mention it
already
in this he starts writing these books
called the solar ponds stories that and
they're they're very closely based on
Arthur Conan Doyle's Sherlock Holmes
stories and the story is he finds a that
Arthur Conan Doyle no longer intends to
write more Sherlock Holmes stories so he
writes him a letter and he says hey if
you don't want to write any more stories
I'd really be happy to do that can can I
have permission Arthur Conan Doyle it's
getting a letter from this guy in the
middle of Wisconsin he has no idea what
the hell does this person is he says
definitely no you cannot do that you
know don't do that I'll sue you if you
do and what is Cinderella do
he says that's fine almost right about
this guy solar ponds who is a detective
and he uses you know deduction and
fascination to figure things out and he
has a doctor friend it was better to war
yeah he's got a landlady and he starts
publishing these things through Arkham
house and eventually Arthur Conan
Doyle's sons after Arthur Conan Doyle
has died they try to you know they try
to stop him by legal means and the case
you know in
is you know essentially thrown out and
he just keeps publishing these he
publishes a lot of I think there's
there's seven or eight ponds Nam or
volumes you know so that's you know
that's kind of an interesting thing and
that will go into when we talk about him
being a well we might these days call a
fan fiction writer and the nature of fan
fiction but anyway going on so he winds
up being president of Associated fantasy
publishers in the 1950s he gets married
and I have not been able to track down
much information on this woman that he
marries Sandra have Evelyn winters he
has two kids with her April rose and
Walden who goes by the name Wally and
after just six years of marriage he
divorces now he gets custody and here in
Wisconsin in the 1950s for a man to get
custody full custody of the children
that was pretty rare so either she just
didn't want to be involved with the kids
or she must have done something that got
her in a lot of trouble but then you
know that was pretty unusual and he
keeps custody of the kids at this time
he's also starting to publish a lot more
though the Lovecraftian stuff that's his
stuff so the survivor and others the
mask of Cthulhu which is a set of short
stories some notes on a nonentity the
shuttered room and other pieces those
are sort of taking Lovecraft stuff and
saying it's a collaboration the trail of
Cthulhu comes in 1962 that's an actual
novel although it's kind of episodic
it's divided into five main sections
each of which
yeah an account so there's a the
manuscript of Andrew felon the desk the
deposition of Abel Keane the testament
of Clairborne Boyd the statement of
Mahlon column and the narrative of
Horvath blamed each of which is like
they're connected to each other but it's
not one single narrative that runs
through the whole thing yeah well what I
mean is that every Cthulhu story that
that Derleth tells there's going to be
some passage in there that basically
lays out the whole Cthulhu Mythos you
know and it's almost like he assumes a
reader who hasn't read any of the other
stuff you know or he's just trying to
drive to the point well you know he you
know with his stuff he didn't have to do
that because it's his own press so yes
is it just like the old Doctor Who
episodes were you know they're not sure
the kids were tuning into the earlier
ones they have to have somewhere or
someone the episode where they explain
exactly what's going on you know yeah
that actually was a a pulp device right
because you know often have these so
it's also something that was in
serialized novels like you know Dickens
or Dostoevsky there's there's you have
to have these sort of reference
referential vignettes to to help the
reader along that doesn't
Lovecraft do that in reanimate er
because it was serialized Oh section he
had yeah I mean would it come before
yeah he does
I don't he may do it some other places
as well I think it happens in the
mountains of madness as long as that was
serialized when I first came out yeah I
mean it's it's a kind of a common what
do you want to call a trick or a trellis
or something I have to do and and when
when a when I was novels being produced
out of that stuff then if there's good
editing take place taking place they
could they could probably get rid of
that stuff right I think in a lot of
cases that just doesn't happen you know
so in any case he he he switches jobs in
60 begins publishing this Hawk and
whippoorwill magazine and resigns from
the capital time so then I think in part
that allows him to be at home more often
he's not gonna live that much longer
after that he dies in 71 he's still you
know churning stuff out in 1969 I was I
was actually just talking about my with
us with my dad earlier today this poor
guy he he goes to the hospital because
he's not feeling good and they you know
you thinks he needs to have a
gallbladder operation so he gets there
and among the things that they find that
are wrong with him he's got hepatitis
and has had it for years he has a
collapsed lung
it was his living yeah I mean he was a
really physical guy so maybe he just
thought well this is just slowing down
yeah this two years later dies of a
heart attack yeah and it was probably
because of all the stresses his body was
under you know it's funny too because
one of the interviews that I read about
he where where the person is complaining
about how how he couldn't get straight
answers from Derleth
you know love perhaps racism which we'll
talk about in a bit he mentions that
he's interviewing he's interviewing
Derleth at Arkham House and in like in
between the shells are hidden away
behind them their list pulls out a box
and Chips Ahoy cookies and he's he's
doing the interviews munching happens so
you can you can imagine that this guy
was probably not you know living the
most healthy lifestyle I think a lot a
lot of times you know when your own when
you're your own boss and you're doing
things like editorial work it's pretty
easy to you know fall into bad habits
isn't it I mean I I know I I do a lot of
client based work and I know I you know
it's easy to put in long hours and bad
and stuff you know so but in any case
yeah he goes into the hospital and I'm
sure you know when he when he ends up
dying of a heart attack this guy
wandering steps back in for Arkham House
because now you actually have a going
concern
Arkham House has got lots and lots of
publishing to do so wand rating says
he'll he'll act as editorial director
temporarily and he's only there for
about a year some other people take over
after that meanwhile April goes off and
gets her college degree and then comes
back and she takes over as the director
of the the press for a while she
unfortunately dies pretty young she's
around 57 when she dies she was not in
the best of health
Wally is is still around he went down to
Texas for a long time
came back to Wisconsin does you know
some deejaying
on some radio station the only other
thing that I put in there is that in
1972 there was a nice recognition for
Derleth in that the British Fantasy
Society [ __ ] live August Derleth award
I suspect that they probably they
probably wouldn't give him the award so
this is a good place to jump in and talk
about some of the some of the
philosophical themes and it's a little
bit different with this than it is with
some of the other authors that we've
looked at because I think one of the big
themes that we have to tackle right off
the bat is thinking about dureth as a
creative writer what is his real
contributions and with the Wisconsin
stuff that it's unmistakable you know
he's got a huge body of work but that's
not speculative fiction when it comes to
the speculative fiction stuff which
largely we would say falls into the
weird tails many which are Lovecraftian
or the solar pond stuff he also wrote a
little bit of science fiction much of
what he's doing is really I think what
we would nowadays describe as fan
fiction where you you take somebody
else's well-constructed characters or
tropes or narratives or stuff like that
and then you you write your own thing
right and we have all sorts of varieties
of that from people who are doing a very
serious job with that to people who just
want to make characters kiss you know
people doing sort of like revenge
stories using them and there's you know
anybody can write about anybody they
want right if I decide I want to write
some more door sign novels
I think the dicks in a state could
probably get get on me if I use all the
terms but if I change them a little bit
there's nothing they can do and actually
if I publish it on the web
nobody's gonna stop me anyway because
whatever site I have to take it down
from I'll just put it in another site
but I don't write fanfiction did any of
you write fanfiction what which has
actual legal team interesting really so
search by like what fans of it's written
for reading and content warnings they're
just a really robust tagging system
that's interesting yeah I mean the the
internet affords us so many
possibilities that just wouldn't have
been around during the pulp era and in
their word I mean it gets more
complicated with the Lovecraft thing
whereas Arthur Conan Doyle said nobody
should publish any Sherlock Holmes
stories and dureth wasn't the only
person publishing Holmes stories on the
side there were lots of other people and
they did the the effect of like that
sort of takedown notices right Lovecraft
encouraged and so you mentioned Clark
Ashton Smith right and I don't you
mentioned Macon right
and then there was Howard and a bunch of
other people who during Lovecraft's life
took a stand at writing
Lovecraft and stuff and then there's
other people after his death who's
written a lot of very good Lovecraftian
stuff and I think Lovecraft was pretty
pretty cool he didn't he didn't seem to
be too concerned about making sure that
you know everybody had to meet a certain
standard or anything like that but you
know the question is well how how should
we look at this fan fiction you know
what would determines whether is really
first of all what determines whether
it's faithful to the source material and
then what determines whether it's real
good how do we how do we and you know
you've got a lot more experience with
this or a thing how do people decide
that with fan fiction I don't read a lot
of fan fiction well I guess yeah that
would be the other question should we
should we have a more elevated term you
know for things that manage to take a
given set of characters or land or set
of assumptions and they they produce
something really high quality that's
material basically it's somebody like a
road to sequel to gone with the wind
okay
Scarlet's enslaved half-sister if I'm
recalling correctly and it's like that
it's plasto's literature but it's a
response to the original yeah you know I
forget the name of the author the guy
who wrote the Grendel a tease that's
very different than available you know
cuz Grendel's are good not exactly good
guy but just not as bad of a guy a bear
was the real jerk you know in in those
cases you've got some sort of reversal
taking place though right yeah I think
we have a lot of you know if you think
about like the musical Wicked
it's doing I just wrote in a diary oh
yeah yeah yeah you know let's get a new
perspective on this or you can sort of
mix and match like
the musical into the woods which I
particularly like in part because I like
the the witch's discourse where she's
like distinguishing you know being nice
from being good from being just from
being right you know and saying being
nice is it's not you know what it's
cracked up to be but an endurance case
we have somebody who's whole you know
whole hog taking over Lovecraft's
universe and then writing his own
stories within it and then also changing
the universe in important ways and it's
debatable to about you know whether it
is writing is that the same quality as
as Lovecraft's some people actually say
it's nice because it makes Lovecraft
more readable but I'm not sure that
that's that's as good of a thing I I
don't know so those of you who've read
the dureth and have read Lovecraft when
you put them side by side would you say
journalist is as good as a writer as
well craft is no he's a lot less purple
yeah I look crap she's using weird words
and he might not always be using them
correctly but at the very least was
interesting yeah and that was one word
that he really loves rigmarole any time
that somebody's like giving him some
sort of some story and he doesn't like
the character they're giving him a
rigmarole you know somebody else pointed
out that he likes there's an
architectural term it's a gambrel that
shows up an awful lot in there as well
yeah well craft you know he he has this
vocabulary of his own I don't know the
three of us maybe in the Wisconsin stuff
he does but I haven't read that
he also has the tendency to like sorry
good I swear he italicizes the last
sentences of every story like trying to
make it more impactful and horrifying
some other people have criticized him
for that as well yeah like four solid
lines of italics that would point the
effect is long since warm oh yeah I mean
maybe that is something that works
better in a pulp setting you know
reading it by candlelight or something
like that I'm not sure if I've read I
need earth it's just specifically but I
know I've read some Lovecraft yeah I've
often found Lovecraft dialogue almost
impossible to get through well he also
writes a little of it as obviously he
knew that himself yeah there are a whole
lot stories which he had almost no
dialogue
well what craft dozens that a dialog is
indirect discourse no way so there's a
lot of like referring to somebody's
letter that they sent it always feels
like if yeah that's that's true it feels
like if Lovecraft character was being
filmed
it'd be a very informative be very
dramatic and and they'd be very tiring
listen to yeah yeah they already yes
thank you know there have been some
annotations of Lovecraft's
stories in film and I don't recall any
of them being particularly good like
random a there's a lot of fun yeah
that's true though that's what none of
them are what you would call great a
films there is the one that's got and
it's sort of loosely based on Lovecraft
stuff it's got it was done in the I
think of 90s
blanking on the name of the they didn't
one that was loosely based on the shadow
over Innsmouth called cultivate Dagon
sci-fi is that right yeah that was a
terrible yeah sci-fi channel doesn't
usually pull that off no this was this
had Sam Mele in it
oh no oh madness I'm sorry the other Sam
yes
event horizon was actually a really good
it's hard to figure out what yeah I know
that was actually you know what's his
name John Carpenter did that oh you know
maybe a lot of that whenever they about
film all supposed to do it like who you
have you know directed and because you
know that I saw the Dunwich horror and
holy that is a terrible and there are
proposals to like redo it but no I don't
think anybody needs to pulled it off so
now I wasn't impressed within the mouth
of madness either had to say I liked it
you know I thought I thought it was it
was decent it's it's hard to see how you
would actually make a lot of this work
huh so one of the things that to shift a
little bit one of the things that for my
impression Lovecraft stories are able to
really convey this notion of cosmic
horror yeah you know sort of like the
bottom drops out of everything that's
one of the things I liked about event
horizon to you you you know there is
there something horrible you can't even
really get your head around it or
describe a beyond description of
insanity
Terkel death doesn't manage to pull that
off Derleth there is there is horror but
it's a little bit too contained in part
because he systematizes things are get
too much and I think when you're doing a
movie it's it's it's hard to resist that
temptation to make everything kind of
fit I
you know another movie that was kind of
I remember it being very scary when I
watched it I haven't seen it for a long
time was was Prince of Darkness it's
it's very strange in that way I would
call it crafty because yeah it's so
utterly surreal and it doesn't find
itself yeah that was part of what made
it so scary were those transmissions
coming from the future and you're right
they didn't I didn't bother to explain
it like this that contains the devil and
it's dripping off word onto the ceiling
yeah that's it and like none of this is
really explained which I feel is
Lovecraftian about it because it's a
sort of like this thing beyond sanity is
yeah I mean Lovecraft provides
explanation up to a point and then you
have to exert your imagination beyond
that and that's what produces the effect
whereas Derleth he's perfectly willing
to explain everything over and over and
over again so so actually let's make a
transition to talking about his
reinterpretation of the Cthulhu Mythos I
created a handout for you specifically
on that Derleth does two things he
thanks he rearranges the mythos and
while he comes up with the word mythos
to begin Lovecraft prefer to call it yog
saga theory Yaya goth is one of the
great old ones what is like if that's
really the term Lovecraft used that's
interesting because that's not the name
of the great old one
the you're thinking of like the the
other ones called the ensemble oh I I'm
mispronouncing oh okay I wasn't sure if
Leakey came up with a set daughter go to
CNS be like Oh puppy dogs and sausage
here's going I mean that's kind of cool
about it is it implies that you're just
like you can actually quite generous and
letting people you know play around with
these ideas and encouraging them Derleth
turns it into a mythos and Derleth you
know he he likes that word mythos in
part there's actually like a whole
discussion of it on his part in I think
it's at the very end of this he says he
says this in an essay but he says this
over and over again in the stories - he
says that here we go the Cthulhu Mythos
is a myth pattern developed gradually by
the late HP Lovecraft
in the final phase of his creative work
and then here there's a there's a quote
that Derleth attributes the Lovecraft
that people who spent way more time on
this trying to track it down they say
Lovecraft didn't actually say this this
is a paraphrase of something that may
have been in a letter Lovecraft side is
based on the fundamental or legend that
this world was inhabited at one time by
another race who had practicing black
magic lost their foothold and were
expelled yet live on outside ever ready
to take possession of this earth again
and then it's appears with Derleth says
its similarity to the Christian mythos
as well as to other myth patterns common
to both history and fiction will be
immediately apparent to the literate
reader so yeah and and so Derleth is
reading in to the you know Cthulhu stuff
this this this mythos that he says is
there and all these other
you know religions or legends and one of
the most notable things about like
Lovecraft's Cthulhu stories is that
there are no similarity to the Christian
miracles yeah well it gets it gets
better so here's here's a journalist
says the staties of Lovecraft's Cthulhu
Mythos considered consistent first of
the Elder Gods which through though
beyond mundane morality beyond good and
evil were nevertheless proponents of
order and thus represented the forces of
enlightenment as against the forces of
evil represented by the ancient ones or
the great old ones who rebelled against
the other gods right sort of like the
Fallen Angels and we're thrust then he
says like Satan into the outer darkness
the Elder Gods existed in or near
Betelgeuse in the constellation Orion
very rarely stirring forth to intervene
in the incessant struggle between the
powers of darkness seeking to gain
control and the races of earth so what
we've got here is a sort of loosely
Christianized sort of like a milkman
kind of Christianity more than more than
traditional catechesis that sounds like
some Catholic reading into yeah there
there's only there's only one elder God
mentioned and that's notice and that's
not in there yeah that's it's in a
strange house yeah it's not it's not in
the Cathars right and then every time
that Lovecraft talks about Elder Gods
which is very rarely it's always not
capitalized and they don't play any role
whatsoever they play a role that Derleth
stuff and it gets even better Derleth
not only sort of brings in a sort of
Christian thing
and and you know transforms the other
gods and they're the great old ones and
to basically demons of some sort they
also tie in with the elements so Cthulhu
water of course right ha stir air should
[ __ ] up goat with a thousand young I
guess that's kind of fit in different
you know and there's not a lot of
explanation of a giant bowl yeah he does
a lot more with the water and the air
than he does with anything else that
really doesn't do much with with the the
fire thing and then there's all these
like complex connections and he'll he'll
in his stories he'll tell this he'll
have the character find a document which
tells this story so here's here's one
from the mask of Cthulhu right he says
he there's something that he finds in
the Miskatonic library it would appear
that the first inhabitants of altar
space were great beings not in human
shape or called the great other gods
against these certain elemental ancient
ones also called the great old ones had
rebelled and then he tells us who they
are as is auth yogs
Sabbath the amphibious Cthulhu the bat
like Hofstra the unspeakable lawyers are
effect while the wind Walker and the
earth beings normal Thep and should
[ __ ] wrath but their rebellion failing
they were cast out and banished by the
other gods locked away on far planets
and stars under the seal of the other
dads
because dulu deep under the sea in the
place known as relay Hester on a black
star elder bond sorry all the of the bar
out in the high eighties he goes on and
on and on right and then he says since
this initial rebellion which is
basically in a legend pattern parapara
paralleling the rebellion of Satan and
his followers against the Archangels of
heaven the great old ones that
continually sought to regain their power
to war against the other gods and there
have grown up on earth and other planets
certain cultists and followers so the
Cthulhu's so Lovecraft's sort of lesser
monsters they're all connected with
these so the abominable snowman the
dolls the deep ones these are all
dedicated to serve the ancient ones
and then you know what is what is the
role of human beings well we're the only
race that actually like tries to you
know keep this this bad stuff from
happening so those human beings have a
central thing so we got a lot of moving
parts here that are very very different
than Lovecraft and they they keep coming
up in story after story after story and
these mythos stories which does make
them kind of anonymous you know you
wonder why why they always have to find
the same you know basic narrative also
mention too that these characters in
Derleth story they inevitably have
access to the same library books and
Derleth you know like with Lovecraft
right you may find reference to a guy
having the Necronomicon or the you know
you know in yeah cult yeah the the
unspeakable or inexpressible cults
there's others as well and yeah Derleth
makes up a couple new ones of his own
like the relay manuscript
oh the panic planktonic manuscript is
another one right the cult de ghouls you
know yeah well here's the thing
Derleth you know he'll like put these
into a long and like a paragraph and and
you know inevitably they're all at the
Miskatonic library to begin with but
they'll also be in this person study or
they'll haven't had the opportunity to
like read all of these and you're like
there's only it's supposed to be five
copies of the Necronomicon floating
around out there how do these people you
know it's almost as if they're they're
part of one big lending
and I think it ruins the effect
absolutely I kind of wonder with Darla
you know did he not know that this was
going to be the effective what is what
he's doing here what did our campus
release it it felt like it was a little
bunch of different stories that we're
never meant to be put between the same
two covers because they're too similar
to each other yeah that's that's that's
a good way to put it and then though the
irony is when he's not writing Cthulhu
based horror and he's just writing like
regional horror about haunted houses or
stuff like that he's actually pretty
good you know it's when the Cthulhu
Mythos gets involved again it's like
fanfiction where he's such a fanboy that
he's got to throw every single element
like you're talking about you know if
you think about like superhero stuff
right let's say you got a great story in
the Marvel Universe and I like you know
the x-men and Cyclops quite a bit
because I kind of grew up on that so
let's say we've got you know this this
great storyline was or Cyclops is you
know finding out who he is and stuff
like that you don't need to actually
have every other character coming in or
every other motif coming in to tell that
story you can just tell that one story
so I think that's what Lovecraft does
right he he introduces us to like in the
Call of Cthulhu we have we have this
this figurine of Cthulhu and this this
detective finds out that there's a
worshipping thing going on and
you know they they they go in and kill
some of the worshipers and interrogate
the rest and start realizing that
there's more and more to this story but
they don't bring in a whole bunch of
other Lovecraftian beings to make sense
of the story they stick with that aspect
what were the very ignorant of the
people who are investigating this as to
you know what else is going on that is
not necessary because these people don't
necessarily know the whole you know what
else might be out there so you don't
have to show it
i'msorry on you know that's a good point
some of the characters and the Derleth
stories are ignorant in that way but
unfortunately they run into other
characters who like know it all and that
that kind of ruins the effect so you
know we in some ways we could criticize
Derleth for what he does to the in
creating Cthulhu Mythos but we can also
say that even if he even if you did all
that sort of so he could have written it
better
you know more thoughtfully so maybe
those are two different grounds for
criticism and complaints I mean that
said I didn't find them they had to read
you know I I find some authors where I
pick it up and like I can't read this
crap well they were enjoyable but it
feels like it's falling short you know
one of the other things I did want to
talk about though maybe there's a bit of
a Redemption form is the importance of
Arkham House you know so we we can say
well this isn't exactly what you know
Lovecraft had in mind but then we're
sort of judging it by you know Lovecraft
himself was able to generate but Derleth
is the is the person who actually was
able to get Lovecraft republished if
only by creating his own publishing
house it's really debatable whether
anybody else would have been able to to
do that we might have lost love crafts
work he might be very obscure he would
have had the influence and as a
preservative lovegrass material he's
invaluable
yeah and that seems to be where his
legacy really lies in terms of people
who know about him they generally know
about it because of Arkham yeah an
Arkham host did a lot more to you know
so that I think that's pretty important
he seems to have been somebody who had a
really good head for figuring out what
would actually be publishable and what
would wouldn't and that and that takes a
certain kind of certain kind of
intelligence that's not exactly the same
that produces cosmic horror but I you
know what we have is is largely due to
to his preservation of it so that's that
seems to be quite important so I mean
that goes that goes into the legacy
another thing that I mentioned those is
Lovecraft was indeed you know very
racist it's interesting because I was
reading one of his letters as I was
trying to find that the Derleth ones and
I don't remember who he was writing to
but man did was he was definitely a
racist of the sort of wasp type LHIN
purity thing is something with he you
know so in this letter he's describing
how different places have problems with
different ethnicities and he you know
used to say that that you know
Californians have trouble and you just
call them the Japan Oh Chinese even in
my distinguished right and you know
Louisiana and Mississippi with with
african-americans and of course he
didn't use the word african-american and
and he's going through like place after
place after place and then he said a New
England our problem is with these Latins
and by that he means that he had
epithets for each one of them he he's
talking about the Portuguese the
Italians French Canadians
and you know you think about it nowadays
if somebody's a white nationalist
they're not going to say that like
Portuguese or Italians or Fred or French
people are not white for Lovecraft they
weren't you know it was anglo-saxons
oh it was also in a letter to where he
was he was talking about Jews and he's
he you know he really didn't like Jews
in general they really didn't like
Asiatic Jews as opposed to European Jews
and he comes out and he says that the
Puritans what was wrong with them is
well they were you know good English
stock they allowed themselves to be
misled by this Jewish book this is early
on in his career so Lovecraft would say
things like that pretty routinely and it
shows up in his stories there's one in
particular of the horrid yeah oh yeah
well but any any time that he has a
chance to describe a degenerate group of
people you know you know and the Cthulhu
thing if I remember right there's some
cages involved right yeah well those are
clearly degenerate yeah they're all the
various yeah and you know he complains
about Providence itself being overrun
with with you know Portuguese and
Italian
I believe actually in Herbert Lester
animator he suggests at one point that
one of West's failures is this black
boxer who died means he suggests that he
fails because the blacks are right cure
enough yeah yeah like is like isn't a
high enough race for him to be
reanimated or something so so they're
live you know it gets asked about this
sort of thing and his take on it was I
wasn't really serious about that sort of
stuff he was just joking around and and
clearly that's not the case like to play
a yeah I a lot of his letters toward the
end of his life is all crafted repent of
all this that's true yeah these are the
fascism thing too Howard didn't say like
I wish I had done done differently that
doesn't change the fact that it's all in
his writing up to that point but I think
most of you've met him toward the end of
his life you could have at least gone
like oh he used to think those things
but he decided differently yeah if you'd
lived another ten years maybe you know I
think he would have said yeah maybe I
mean a lot of it seems to have been very
visceral like in a very well you know
Derleth in publishing some of Lovecraft
stuff did actually change things now he
didn't do that with the letters he left
them more or less as they are although
you do see a lot of dot dot dots where
things might have been taken out well
Lovecraft - he he died before World War
Two was up yeah and if he was already
changing in in the late 20s early 30s it
knows what yeah I think what I could
have had yeah at the same time to say
the to say is that I'm sure Daryl it did
that like he didn't believe in any of
this ever is to definitely bounder eyes
them yeah it seems it seems disingenuous
because if he thinks Lovecraft didn't
believe in that why change the wording
to just you know sort of saw shoot
somebody sounds like something a
Salesman would do yeah I guess that's a
good point
or someone apologizing want older
relatives yeah yeah yeah like oh that's
this Graham but starting something like
Arkham House be at least from the
beginning for the primary purpose of
like having this guy's your client ship
yeah to do try and like soft
settle that and say like oh I mean he
said a few things but it's just obvious
time you what did it it it I mean that
makes a lot of sense and they are from a
different there are two different
generations so it actually does like fit
the older relative thing quite well yeah
that makes that makes a lot of sense
the last thing when I was gonna bring up
as a fill of sort of philosophical theme
and we can certainly talk about other
ones that you guys would like to put on
the table is it's just sort of a
question like what makes a mythos you
know we've got the Cthulhu Mythos and
this guy I think this kind of ties in
with world building because we don't
have we don't have a narrative world in
a way that like fantasy writers do or
science fiction authors do
like you know they create a whole you
know this race and these people and
here's their monetary system and all
that sort of stuff it's set in our world
but it's like lovecraft you know pulls
back the veil and says ah there's all
this crazy stuff going on behind the
scenes that most of us don't know about
and you know there's no literally no
bottom to it here's a few vignettes of
it and we don't actually know how all
these parts are connected together
during the it's much more systematic and
you know maybe there is a bottom to it
that that's provided by the Elder Gods
but what what actually makes a narrative
universe that we can call a mythos and I
don't actually have a good answer for
this why do we call it the Cthulhu
Mythos and not just like you know the
Cthulhu cycle or something like that
well I think it's some level it's kind
of like a distinction made by each
individual person encounters it lets go
they're not late I mean I think we call
it the Cthulhu Mythos because that's
what everybody's been calling it but I
think in terms of what what makes a myth
a myth
yeah much like just like August earlier
than what he's done to it it seems to me
like the thing that if we're going to
look for a good definition permit the
thing that makes him myth I mean is that
it lives on beyond the author who
created it and sends out its tendrils
into other okay yeah the symbology are
dealing with his discussion of what what
he considers a myth and in his case it's
that you have room for variant versions
yeah the car goes up and that there's
room for all these different variants
kind of like how yeah I mean it reminds
me of like when we talk about like Greek
mythology right there they're these
popular books out there like you know
put out and they well there were these
twelve gods you know the Pantheon and
all that and when you look at like
source material like the hymns to the
gods that that are preserved or hassey
it or homer or something like that
it's way more more complicated and murky
and stories don't match with each other
exactly well on the Greeks have this
tradition to it like going somewhere
else and and you know saying that kind
of looks like it's Aries we're gonna
tell that the Aries of this or that's
the Artemis of this you know and the
local people would probably be like
that's not that guy at all and the
Greeks of you like yeah you usually just
akin if you're in the Old Testament in
the Bible there are obviously stories in
there that were put in there by the
compilers the Old Testament that they
don't understand why they're there and
that sometimes even go against what they
say their God you know like wants or
doesn't want like the whole thing with
Abraham having to you know get like
asked by God to slaughter his son goes
directly against like the the covenant
with God yeah I was so important and yet
it's clear that the people who were
writing the Old Testament don't know why
the story is in there because it seems
but it's part of their middles partly I
think at the tall one with people
arguing and actually forth about every
kid only did a bit of that that's
already about and and sometimes they'll
say this is their best guess you know
right it was part of this shared and
length that you're saying yeah I mean if
we're everyone had this like we
different perspective
- suddenly contradictory versions I mean
I like that actually because then one of
them is much more sort of you know
gender equality you know and and the
fact that there's two of them in there I
mean it led to though that whole like
wait a second who is this first woman
and then you know Lilith sort of extra
stuff coming again which is which is
interesting
you know my favorite Abraham's story
this will this may sound a little gross
but this because I think about like what
this must have been like so you know
Abraham makes a covenant with God right
and part of that covenant is
circumcision now when we think about you
know who Abraham was he was essentially
what we were nowadays called like a clan
leader and at that time he had a whole
bunch of families that were he was he
was essentially ruling over so it wasn't
just him moving to get circumcised it
was all the males in there and you think
about the technology that they had stone
knives so now imagine you know telling
all these these people that you're
responsible for listen guys I've had
this conversation with God and he wants
me to do this thing not just to me but
to all of you so line up because it's
gonna be a rough day cross your fingers
that you don't get census yeah exactly
you know and I mean I'm one of their one
of the stories that we have about
circumcision later on is in book of
Judges right where Dinah is raped and
her brothers you know they're they're
gonna they're first they're gonna go
kill the guys who did it and then they
say now you have to you have to become
one you have to become one of us you
have to get circumcised so these other
guys are like well okay I guess we'll
get circumcised and then while they're
laid up in bed
the brothers come in and slaughter them
because I really enjoy the book of
Judges but that's in part because it's
like the the crazy wild
you know it's sort of like the epic
stuff the Bible you know and if it isn't
one actually that is one thing I do like
about the Bible is people will talk
about it as if it's one single document
and and no it's this that's top biblia
all these books and some of them are
some of them are quite frankly quite
boring like Chronicles but but others
are you know there's you're like how the
hell did this get in here oh yeah
ghostly hands writing on the wall and
true yeah yeah rocking bowl yeah and you
don them there's the Psalms and those
are very interesting and the other
wisdom literature you know but that's
very different say than say you know
Joshua Oh which is essentially about
genocides
oh yeah clearly asking as part of that
wisdom literature and then there's
ecclesiasticus the church book also
called Ciroc what's up it's it's it's
it's I was telling about this with a
friend of mine who's having a midlife
crisis and he was concerned with you
know he thinks that there's good reason
to think there is in life after death
and he's been you know he grew up in a
Christian home and the Bible you know
their perspective nobody's really you
know treated this they've all been
dogmatic but I was like wait a second
what about Ecclesiastes you know that
guy he's like yeah we're just turned
into dust but he doesn't say also I
screw it I'm just gonna do whatever the
hell I want
he says there's still the law and
there's still something good about you
know following the law even if we don't
completely understand it so it's not
totally pessimistic there there's
there's this weird optimism running
at the end well it doesn't that rock
bottom idea of like do the right thing
anyway yeah and so this guy was
struggling with the idea of if you take
you know God in the afterlife out of the
picture does that mean morality falls
apart and he's a you know he's a
detective in Kankakee so that's a rough
town he's got you know a a young kid
he's you know thinking about some real
life issues and so you know CLE zs T's
is there to maybe provide an answer
that's not a full answer job is like
that too you know I mean at the very end
you know everyone's like oh gods kind of
a jerk because he's like who are you to
question me but but if you if you read
it I mean it's a philosophical dialogue
to begin with but you look at what's
going on where it ends isn't isn't with
God saying you know shut up job you know
all of you are idiots or anything like
that it actually ends with job having to
argue with God sort of like Abraham does
to try to save Sodom on behalf of his
friends who are the real screw-ups and
trying to say hey be merciful to them
don't don't smite them for for their you
know I guess intellectually bereft
jackassery or something like that you
know I really doesn't use those words
yeah what I think it's like being a
parent everything in there you don't
understand I'm the one that knows
everything you know and it's that's why
I look at
a lot of that work is it's nothing more
than a conversation between us as
children to the parent yeah and he can't
explain what we can't understand at the
moment oh and so much and it seems like
you know these people trying to say we
are looking for some way for all of us
to live together without murdering each
other yeah and and we'll come up with
any any way we can to to bring that
about like either rules and laws or
saying you know whatever is the success
keep society alive but I'm like I always
like to point out to my kids I'm like if
you really look at the Bible and start
pulling it apart and like there talks
about reincarnation over and over in
there which we refuse to see as you know
and I was born and raised Catholic and
I'm like every point you look at that
I'm like we're coming back you better
make sure because that person killed me
end up being your son or your daughter
or whatever and trust me that whole
karmic type thing you know ends up
coming about I think a lot of times you
know and it's funny because I you know I
mean I hate to bring up Stephen but yeah
my my son my oldest son is adopted and
my daughter kept telling me hey there's
this baby coming by there's this baby
coming by and I'm looking at her like
blood and lo and behold I had a friend
of a friend of a friend come knocking on
the door saying hey we've a baby we want
oh and Charlie for adoption and here's
this baby so I always told when they
have issues with one another you
remember you brought him here you saw
him coming my sister and I both adopted
and we used to joke with each other you
know and there was sort of a common
practice when I was adopted because the
previous generation they wouldn't tell
kids that they were adopted and then a
lot of them would like find out and kill
themselves or getting undressed and so
from from like you know whenever we
learned how to understand or speak they
told us that we were adopted and we
would joke with each other and say you
know mom and dad loved me more because
you're
because you know there is that that sort
of notion that that was the case but I
mean in my family was kind of cool
because they we never got treated any
differently than anybody else would my
large extended family you know what I
just don't get
but ties in to the readings and things
like that so that's it yeah that's a
good sort of circle back to this
Lovecraft opens up the certain kind of
like there's more going on here than
than we know and in our in our yeah in
our own life stuff very often there's
and sometimes we have to get bold enough
to actually be able to process it too
there's there's always a lot of stuff
like that even even if my families that
seem to be really well put together
they'll be like some secret drama some
hidden loss some some trauma that never
got dealt with you know and I'm not
saying everybody has to like err
everything all the time that's probably
not a good thing because we probably
couldn't function if we did you know and
we can also talk about to a sort of
larger scale like you know we think
about how people you know relate to each
other outside of the family and are in
our societies and what gets papered over
and you know what what what losses took
place I mean I think maybe some of
hormuz a div a different point some of
horror maybe has it's it's or Weird
Tales maybe as it's forced because it
plays off of that stuff the notion that
there's more going on and that we
really processed I think with Lovecraft
that was definitely going on during lift
it's harder to say again I wish I wish I
had read the Wisconsin stuff because
then I could speak competently about it
maybe he had something like that with
writing about the landscape the people
of his town you know I don't know how
many of you read the Wisconsin yeah what
was your impression it was maybe maybe
the stuff doesn't age very well then you
know I mean when we talk about American
regional literature there's some authors
who are like that stuff we still gotta
keep reading because it's really
[Music]
you